this is lan seaport where customs checks
are carried out on goods arriving in
northern ireland from great britain
under the post-brexit northern ireland
protocol
it established a customs border within
the united kingdom itself as a way of
protecting the eu's single market while
avoiding a hard border on the island of
ireland
the protocol is now at the heart of an
escalating dispute between the uk and
the eu and has led to the breakdown of
power sharing government in northern
ireland i am announcing our intention to
introduce legislation in the coming
weeks to make changes in the protocol
our preference remains negotiated
solution with the eu
that was the british government
announcing its intention to take
unilateral action if changes to the
protocol can't be negotiated by
promising to enact legislation the hope
is to encourage the eu to compromise and
also to repair devolved government at
stormont by enticing the democratic
unionist party back into power sharing
with the nationalist shin fame
the dup who cautiously welcomed the move
say the protocol undermines northern
ireland's right to equal treatment as
part of the uk
vp warned
about the consequences of this protocol
and that's why we opposed it from the
beginning because we recognize the
political and economic instability it
would cause and the harm it would create
for the union itself
the european union is likely to see this
move by the british government as a
threat and it has warned about the
consequences of unilateral action
potentially including a legal challenge
if they believe the british government
has breached international law
potentially even down the line resulting
in a trade war and as much as the prime
minister of the foreign secretary say
they hope for a negotiated resolution to
all of this it's frankly quite hard to
see the eu capitulating under the shadow
of a threat
the irish foreign minister said it was
damaging to trust with a general lack of
trust already an aggravating factor
i think that is a significant problem in
northern ireland in a recent poll four
percent expressed trust in the uk
government which is a very low percent
for a resident sovereign government and
i think within the conservative party
there's all sorts of games being played
which we don't actually understand
necessarily from here between ministers
and then there's another factor which is
the american factor exactly how would
they want to negotiate their interest in
northern ireland so all of these things
have not yet crystallized and we have to
wait for the consequences
all of which leaves the wider dispute
and northern ireland's problems within
it little closer to resolution jonah
hull al jazeera belfast